you
hi everyone it's Jerry let's have a look
at a game that was played at the tall
Memorial in 1995 on the white end garry
kasparov his opponent Vishy Anand let's
have a look first of all what opening it
is in heavens gambit some of you may
recall the game Bobby Fischer vs. Reuben
fine 1963 that had this same opening and
that game didn't last long
it was only a 17 mover this one here 25
now in the Fisher versus fine game fine
at this moment played Bishop a5 there
are other options and we get to see one
of them here Bishop e7 now if there's
one thing that sticks out to me most
about this game
it is Kasparov's play and how it
resembles alpha zeroes
lela chess to zero the neural networks
why do I think this well there are two
primary features about this game that
kind of stick out to me in particular
the decision Kasparov makes on move
eight we'll see what that is
soon enough d4 in this game how should
you reply is black it's very important
not to just go ahead and snap off this
pawn how many of you playing as black
would just take on d4 and then feel the
pain after your opponent plays Queen to
b3 yeah your king will now go on castled
that's a problem considered best is
Knight a5 at this point and again your
King would be without a cozy home Anand
understands this and says the strength
of your Bishop yeah I don't want you
pointing at my weakest Square that's too
much go away
the bishop flushed back to e2 only at
this point only after the bishop is not
observing f7 does black capture on d4 so
here we are move eight what does
Kasparov play in this position feel free
to pause the video okay
the top move in the engines eyes is to
capture on d4 with upon happy little
ponds right you just restored your pawn
structure it's no longer isolated pawn
duo ideal pawn center a couple different
names for that you're also vacating c3
for the Queen Knight everything seems
wonderful but Kasparov says no to all
that I'm gonna take with the Queen now
this move here is not just a oh I want
to develop a new piece and throw a punch
no the main idea here is to sin is to
use d4 as a pivot to next hang a right
and drift towards the Kings side where
the Queen is going to be a great pest a
great inconvenience to the black king
side structure knight c6 Queen h4 Queen
g3 here we are
note the activity of the white queen
compared to the black queen the black
queen in this game does nothing makes
one move and then basically resigns what
are the two features of this game that
are reminding me of let's say the alpha
zero games in eight alpha zero games
alpha zero had white and in six of those
eight games we saw this exact move on
board efore to e5 and in many of those
six games we saw the Queen connecting
really well with this advance by
drifting over near the King side probing
for some weaknesses trying to induce
moves like g6 the move played in this
game this is what really stuck out to me
this decision Queen d4 Queen g3 here we
are a difficult decision now for black
computer suggests King to f8 go on
Castle don't create a weakness in this
game g6 now the first if there's a first
move that sticks out to me here it is
develop a piece
make use of a weak square and stop your
opponent from castling that makes a real
lot of sense
there may be a downside connected with
that though at the same time White has
some space that's what you get with this
pawn established on e5 that's one of the
things you get you're also scaring away
the the King Knight from its favorite
square f6 White has some space if Bishop
h6 here that will be challenged very
quickly and if there's a dark square
Bishop exchange maybe the Queen will
feel a little bit more comfortable now
she has a square actually to work with
on e7
what does caste Rob do gets castled
retains some options for the dark square
bishop who knows that it has a lot of
different choices let's retain those
options castles on board Knight b6
follows that Knights going to be given a
kick one way or the other c4 rook d1
just anticipating those moves
c4 now and after d6 rook d1 placing
black in a pin black has a good move
here in the game Knight d7 is played the
computer says Knight a 4 is best Knight
a 4 is a pretty slick move what is it
doing it's looking to interfere with
whites Queen side development where do
you think this Knight wants to go c3
well that's ruled out and if you try to
go elsewhere the Knights gonna hop right
in and hit you with a fork Knight a 4
can be quite an inconvenient move to
deal with okay well in this game we have
Knight d7 really trying to put some
pressure on the e5 pawn I mean if this
is not a big focal point in this game
I'm not sure what is Bishop h6 only now
Knight takes couple captures on e5 and
Knight to c3 so here we are what's the
body count five pawns for white white is
down two pawns but I think every single
piece is better for white when when
compared to its counterpart ok this
Knight may be a little bit better than
the knight on c3 but I don't know that I
could
say that this night will be flushed
whenever white wants with f4 black is in
a serious seriously bad position here
it's too late by the way to now
challenge this Bishop on h6 with Bishop
to f8 at this stage now that things have
opened up in the centre some there could
be a capture on f8 if King takes Bishop
Queen takes Knight unprotected Queen
that's a problem Bishop f8 and chop-chop
what is this King doing he's just asking
for trouble things are gonna open up
even further with c5 the king is without
a home what does black do here how to
address this strong post on h6 well the
decision one of the better decisions
computers eyes is f6 a huh the knight
will be the one that gives a punch from
here c5 let's open it up more lines for
the better developed side that's the way
forward pawn exchanges c5 on board
additionally new possibilities for the
bishop continuing Knight f7
shop on d6 recapturing with upon
initially I thought you take with the
Bishop throw a punch at the Queen you
could do that but there are checks and
then follow-up checks
I believe the idea here by taking with
the pawn is to keep the bishop around
kind of shelter the king somewhat from
my rook check on the e-file continuing
we have Queen III some defense of the
Bishop dark square Bishop is gone but
where is the development for team black
it's non-existent how many moves away
from cap let's not even calculate
castling is just only in your dreams
black from here Bishop FA under
developing black has successfully I you
know black is setting up the pieces for
the next game with Bishop FA Queen III
King f7 trying to Castle by hand but
yeah that's it's not just going it's not
going to work Knight d5 on board nice
improvement for the night Bishop e6
Knight to f4 what to do about this
pressure Queen to e7 we're at move 24
just one more move away and well what is
this next move Kasparov plays here that
makes black resign feel free to pause
the video okay the final move of this
game move 25 might be it kind of
difficult one to spot because it is a
little quiet not some capture or check
but rather a rook to e1 move in this
simp this one simple move getting to a
completely open file I know there are
pieces here but moving to this
completely open file is what breaks
black in the end there are some serious
threats connected with this namely to
have some bishop move with the
discovered check or maybe even a double
check so for example let's just say the
rook plays here defending the bishop
what can you do here as white you can
play Queen to d4 I don't believe that's
the only one you could capture on this
Square this is cleanest to capture on e6
and then play Bishop to c4 and what are
you doing if Queen takes bishop that's
going to lose the exchange that's one
way you could take advantage of this of
these light squares soon as you take
that light square bishop this guy
becomes enormous so rook to e8 wouldn't
really be working out if let's say the
bishop moves there can be Bishop c4 and
what does the King do the King goes here
you end up winning a piece and if the
King goes here you end up moving the
Queen somewhere and there's a pin
there's no good defense here I'm not
sure how many other variations consider
maybe this is the last one pawn to d5
you can play Bishop f3 and white is
ready to crash through on the d5 square
so something like this you can take on
e6 and in the end show that that light
square bishop is an absolute monster
there's just no good defense to this
pressure against the e6 point and white
is basically attacking after having a
minimal investment in this game just a
couple ponds all the pieces are playing
for team white so a quick kill in this
one just a 25 mover feel free as usual
to leave any feedback to this video in
the comment section below I hope you
enjoyed it and maybe even took a thing
or two away from it that's all for now
take care bye
you